Speaker 1: Yesterday, we talked about radical
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Greene
being banned from Twitter for her fifth
strike spreading disinformation. And I
told you the details of it and we mentioned, you
know, when these things happen, it's of course
correct. But they immediately turn it into, I'm
the victim. They immediately throw out their
principles of businesses should be allowed to do
what they want as long as it's not illegal. It's
the same tired routine. And now, unfortunately,
it's scaling up even more because Marjorie Taylor
Greene has been suspended from Facebook just hours
after the Twitter ban. This one does not appear
to be permanent. The congresswoman claimed data
showed the COVID 19 vaccine was unsafe. Marjorie
Taylor Greene, the right wing congresswoman famous
for her support of conspiracy theories about the
2020 election, COVID 19 and other issues,
has been temporarily suspended from Facebook
hours after being banned permanently from Twitter.
The congresswoman confirmed her suspension
in a Telegram post, calling the company's
decision beyond censorship of free speech.
Sorry, beyond censorship of speech, her suspension
appeared to result. From the same post that got
her a final fifth strike from Twitter, which led
to her account deactivation a post claiming that
vaccine injury and death reports gathered
by a reporting service operated by the FDA
proved that the government was ignoring large
numbers of deaths resulting from the vaccine. Now
that's untrue, of course. In reality, the data
used by the congresswoman contained anecdotal
reports unverified by the FDA. Clinical trials
have shown the vaccine can have mild side effects
at a handful of serious side effects that are
much rarer. MZ Green originally posted a message
on both platforms, pointing to a large number of
reports of injury or death among COVID vaccine
recipients as evidence that the federal
government was ignoring high amounts of COVID
vaccine deaths. This has become a favorite among
the anti-vax people now. I'm really obviously she
deserves to be banned. The ban from Twitter is
permanent. The ban from Facebook is temporary.
I'm conflicted only in the sense that these
bands are correct, but immediately used to
the advantage of these individuals, and we can't
really do anything about that. I mean, when people
misunderstand what free speech is, when people
misunderstand what censorship is, when people
claim to hold values of businesses
being able to do what's best for them
until it conflicts with
what is convenient for them,
we can't really do anything about the fact that
people like Marjorie Taylor Greene will weaponize
these bans. But now comes the onslaught of the
right wing pundits, confusing the Constitution
with the terms of service of a private company.
Here comes the martyrdom and the entire thing.
Will she say this violates HIPA? I don't think so.
She's known for talking about hip hop, but I don't
think she will actually pull that here. But this
all plays into the narrative, and for all we know,
some of these people, maybe Marjorie Taylor Greene
are deliberately breaching what at this point they
have to know are the terms of service of these
companies in order to get banned in order to
claim that they are being censored to their base
so that they will raise money. It is, after all,
an election year now in 2022. Obviously, Marjorie
Taylor Greene and her ilk deserve to be banned
from these platforms. I'm not contesting that
at all, but they have started to use these bans
almost like Purple Hearts in the culture war. She
was banned from Twitter. She it's the equivalent
of I went and I fought for my country in this
case, her side by tweeting disinformation and they
banned me. And the ban is held up almost like a
Purple Heart medal in their mind. They love being
what they call persecuted, and they immediately
start fundraising off of it. And it is, after all,
ten months until Marjorie Greene's Marjorie
Taylor Green's reelection election. And
it is I. I'm not saying, don't ban them. I'm
merely reminding everybody about the ways in which
they will immediately try to benefit from those
bans. And Marjorie Taylor Greene. I mean, in all
likelihood, is going to sail to reelection easily.
We'll look at some of those poll numbers for her
on Friday. Not going to make a difference
in that sense, but they see these as
worthy injuries sustained in fighting the culture
war that they have created. One other really funny
thing is Facebook has been like a primary source
of not. I don't want to say source. Facebook
has been a primary disseminate her of COVID
disinformation by allowing so much of it over
the last year and a half. And it's funny that now
all of a sudden, they're banning Marjorie Taylor
Greene for for exactly that reason, but they
did ban her. It's temporary she'll be back on.
But I expect the fundraising emails to go
out very, very soon, saying they banned me.
Give me money so I can fight for you and
medical freedom and all this different stuff up